the Joe Rogan experience after the
second I believe it was you just like
this is like this should be stopped
right this should be stopped these dopes
there's no chance and I don't really
watch him get beat up as much so I'm
like tweeting about the fight and
watching and I'm looking back and forth
and they're holy [ __ ] up side down I
love that guy and then Elkins chokes out
Michael Johnson it shows people yes
skills that's that's that's the other
thing there it is right here
I mean we're Saad Beck dick it was super
[ __ ] talented like just an undefeated
coming into this fightin Darren was
covered in blood and he got crucifix
here and he's getting smashed at punches
and elbows but L can't he's just one of
those guys Darren just doesn't give up
man and the other thing about mossad is
Miss uh I've trained on my side my side
trains hard his condition look at his
conditioning is on point
look at this that's great that's so
crazy you know there's another scream
like that when cat Zingano beat Amanda
Nunez yeah it's another one like that
number her victory dude that one is
bone-chilling you hear the scream you're
like whoa hmm like it gets you here like
I might I got goosebumps just thinking
about yeah listen that dude that meant a
lot to her man you can hear it yeah -
that's some [ __ ] you can't fake yeah no
there's something that about what you
were saying though about um people like
walking away from these things it's it
makes me think of like of a kid I'm
sorry this is this is gonna be like a
bunch of things tied into one thing but
babies when they're first born like
first thing to come out of baby usually
a cry right right and it's like my
thought on that is like this is the
first time they felt anything outside of
that womb right and and they don't know
what pain is like a pain tolerance the
first time you got kicked it it hurt a
lot more than it does now yeah right so
like every sensation is new for them
right and then you're growing up and you
grow up to be these people and your
parents are telling you can do anything
but at the same time they telling you
don't do that right right so it's like
like the mind is your brain is this this
is blank slate when you're born and um
you get all these different influences
and this goes back to the people that
are like I can't catch a break I can't
catch a break
it's like oh we are we doing this right
because for so many people have this
attitude yeah you know like what where
where is that coming from because it's
there are so many people like that and
then there are people that are like that
at times and then but they can they can
either come out of it and start having
good things or and then they go back
into and they bounce back and forth but
why are people the way they are like
that the mod the human mind to me is
like the most amazing confusing like
ever it's everything but like there's no
rules yeah I mean everybody's different
they're everybody's similar but
everybody's different and your attitude
has a giant effect not just on your life
but on other people's lives around you
that's the other thing about it those I
can't catch a break guys yeah get them
the [ __ ] away from me I can't I can't be
around those guys I don't want to hear
that [ __ ] I don't want to hear that [ __ ]
I don't buy it
cuz everybody has bad breaks yeah I've
had a [ __ ] ton of bad breaks but you
know what I did I stayed up yeah and I
thought through it and I and I figured
out what the [ __ ] I did wrong and then I
went back it's like I [ __ ] up
everything I've ever done a hundred
times there's no way there's no other
way to do it and I've got a bunch of
shitty breaks everybody has but you got
to realize when you have those shitty
breaks what that is it's an opportunity
for you to reassess reboot get better
figure out another way find another way
through it's just little challenges and
the people that look at those challenges
go world wars have these challenges
they're cancer those people are
dangerous to be around they were robbed
you of your enthusiasm they don't give
you any fuel that the opposite of fuel
yeah like the fuel people they're the
Holden people that are kicking ass the
people that are out there just [ __ ]
hustling always always getting things
done they got like my friend Jocko every
morning I'll check his Instagram page
for 30 shows a picture of his watch get
after it he's out there working out 4:30
in the morning
he does it every [ __ ] morning why
because cuz he doesn't want to that's
how you do it you go and get after you
don't make any excuses and those kind of
guys are fuel but those I can't catch a
break guys they're the opposite of fuel
they're just pissing on your fire
they're no fun and though and then the
people that surround them are all idiots
cuz only idiots want to be around I
can't catch a break guys yeah
only the dummy stick around after a
while even if they're your good friend
you gotta be like bro you got to [ __ ]
stop you got to stop at those I can't
catch a break [ __ ] all the time
you're complaining you could be instead
hustling you could be instead chasing
your dream you could be instead figuring
out what you're doing wrong trying to
prove certain aspects of your life
getting your [ __ ] together reading a
book meditating something [ __ ]
something but this I can't catch a break
[ __ ] it's not helping anybody and it
pushes everybody away from you but some
people they get caught in that pattern
and it might be their parents it might
be how they were raised
somebody might have told them they were
useless real early on it's stuck and
they just they always they never feel
like they get enough reassurance they
never feel like they get enough
motivation and they feel like other
people get more and they look at all
these other people who are computers how
come she gets this how come he's got
that going on and that all that's bad
for you too
that [ __ ] ain't no good for you how much
of that is tied into not paying
attention to yourself not not knowing
yourself you know how much time how much
of that is it's time has tuned into are
tied into you always on like oh your
brain always outside of yourself you you
flushing with your flooding your brain
with TV or Instagram or this you know
and not not something that even even
reading a book I believe is is different
oh when you're watching TV what you're
watching you know what I mean if you're
watching something that that has a
message where you have to think where
you you can see yourself in that and you
can put yourself in these situations and
you're like oh well that's I can
empathize with that or I can this but
when you're just watching oh spend their
money on cars and and you're making it
rain and this and that you know um and
wonder how much of that because like the
thing and I've found is like
entertainment isn't what it used to be
and this this is I'm gonna sell all the
[ __ ] back in my day entertainment like
entertainment wasn't what it is now now
it's just like bright lights and flash
and bombs right first is like something
that you could actually feel I feel like
it's a lot less of that well there's
some entertainment that you could feel
like TV shows you watch black mirror
that'll freak the bleep out of you make
you think there's still some good [ __ ]
that's being made stranger things find
it so much more like I feel like the the
bigger things like the things that most
people have access to I think that's
what it is
right right but is it that they have
more access to that or is that the
easiest thing the easiest thing to to
consume it's very easy to consume it's
mindless and everybody wants cars Lulu
the car everybody wants money look at
his money you know II just get sucked up
in it
and it's a very low level frequency that
everybody sort of has like a little bit
of it and you see some dude with his
open shirt all these chains and he's all
these girls behind him in their
underwear everybody's dancing it's like
this guy's life's a party yeah my life
is a party I can't catch a [ __ ] break
I'm over here I can't catch a boy it's
cool it's cool sometimes you know yeah
but like terms silly yeah exactly
there's a point like like you know who's
a deep guy [ __ ] chilling and shells
very deep yeah and he he he pointed this
out to me through a different way but
there's a point where everything becomes
a bad thing there's a point where like
humility is a bad thing there's a point
where having fun is a bad thing it's
like yeah you can't you can't like
eating doesn't isn't always a pleasure
if you if you're constantly eating if
you're never hungry you don't appreciate
it as much as if you're a hungry
Brian oh yeah is if you're if you're
starving and they feed you and you're
you start you you're full and you have
to keep eating that's not fun right
right right yeah so there is this
moderation thing that I feel that's
missing and I'm trying to find that
balance myself man with what with life
with with with a bunch of different
things with with how much time I spend
doing this versus this especially now
that I'm not fighting because that was
for a long time that was the biggest
part of my day
you know just just trading and
everything else and now I still get to
Train but I have more time and a lot of
time by myself in my own head
[Applause]